l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur le
coût pour les collectivités
territoriales de la crise sanitaire et
économique demandée par le groupe les
républicains la parole est tout d'abord
à l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat j'appelle donc monsieur mathieu
darnaud d'arnaud pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez vous avez huit minutes chers
collègues
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comment ne
pas commencer ce propos par un plaidoyer
une plaidoirie à l'endroit de nos
collectivités et singulièrement de nos
communes monsieur le ministre qui ont
permis finalement d'accompagner
utilement avec l'agilité qu'on leur
connaît l'état pour être au rendez-vous
de cette crise sanitaire pour permettre
finalement à nos concitoyens de pouvoir
bénéficier de l'ensemble d'un dispositif
complet permettant notamment aujourd'hui
la vaccination à grande échelle et au
moment où nous nous apprêtons ici même
dans quelques semaines à étudier un
texte de loi le texte 4d me semble-t-il
nous devons réaffirmer d'une part la
conscience dans nos collectivités
la confiance dans nos communes parce que
aucune n'a échappé de brest à biarritz
de strasbourg à privas à cet exercice
utile et nécessaire nécessaire pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens comme je
le rappelais à l'instant et finalement
ce texte permettra de mettre l'accent
sur la décentralisation sur la
déconcentration
mais d'ores et déjà l'état se doit
selon nous d'être au côté de l'ensemble
de nos collectivités et être aux côtés
de l'ensemble de nos collectivités si
les accompagner financièrement parce
qu'en prenant des décisions au plus haut
sommet de l'état monsieur le ministre
vous avez invité l'ensemble de nos
collectivités encore une fois
singulièrement les communes à engager de
dépenses des dépenses
nécessaire nous ne sommes pas ici pour
le contester
mais je veux remercier notre collègue
jean françois husson et l'ensemble de
notre groupe d'avoir souhaité mettre à
l'ordre du jour de nos travaux cette
discussion pour bien rappeler combien
les collectivités ont su faire oeuvre
utile durant cette crise sanitaire
les chiffres sont là ils ont été
rappelés par un rapport parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale qui fait état de 4
milliards de dépenses un autre par
l'association des maires des franches de
france qui évalue plutôt le le coup à
six milliards en tout état de cause les
chiffres nous montrent combien les
collectivités ont besoin d'être
assistées accompagné combien les coûts
ont besoin d'être évalués pour qu'ils
puissent faire l'objet d'un
accompagnement réel de la part de l'état
4 milliard c'est important mais au-delà
des 4 milliard c'est une baisse de 9% de
l'autofinancement net du bloc communal
c'est aussi une baisse de plus de 15% de
l'investissement ce qui est inédit
inédit et particulièrement préjudiciable
parce qu'on le sait toutes et tous les
collectivités participent pleinement au
développement de notre économie locale
par le biais de la commande publique
il nous faut donc être au rendez-vous et
rappeler pardon combien l'état doit
aujourd'hui m si j'ose dire la main à la
poche
c'est important voire essentiel parce
que si il a été très clairement rappelé
que l'ensemble des accompagnements sur
les centres de vaccination surtout ce
qui a participé de l'organisation de ces
centres de vaccination sur les matériaux
de soins je pense à l'époque au masque
aux blues
tout ce qui a fait que nous avons pu
lutter de la meilleure des façons contre
le virus est contre
ses conséquences toutes ces décisions
ont dû être prises en urgence et les
collectivités et faire preuve d'une
réactivité absolue j'en profite pour
dire que certaines collectivités nous
ont interpellés nous interpelle encore
aujourd'hui parce qu'elles n'ont
toujours pas perçu lors de ces premières
annonces d'accompagnement financier de
l'état notamment sur les masques
l'ensemble des moyens qui leur avait été
promis je sais que c'est relativement
rare aujourd'hui mais encore faut-il
avoir parce que vous le savez mieux que
quiconque monsieur le ministre
beaucoup de nos collectivités et
permettez-moi d'être trivial sont à l'os
et lorsqu'on et vous connaissez
particulièrement bien la ruralité une
petite commune de 300 habitants
j'en connais une dans mon département sa
montagne ardéchoise le bh qui a dû
prendre un employé qui va générer une
augmentation 12000 euros de ses coûts de
fonctionnement
eh bien on se doit d'être accompagné par
l'état lorsque la conséquence de cet
emploi n'est autre que la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons mais les
dépenses sont d'autres natures permettez
moi d'en citer quelques-unes qui passent
parfois assez inaperçu je viens d'un
département qui a une vocation très
touristique l'emploi des saisonniers
c'est un impact considérable
la baisse de certains revenus sont là
aussi des impacts considérables
je pense notamment à la taxe de séjour
qui constitue une baisse de recettes de
15% dans un département comme le mien la
baisse des billetteries des grands sites
touristiques
je pense notamment à l'aven d'orgnac et
on a là l'espace de restitution de la
grotte chauvet en ardèche
les baisses de recettes pour des
communes qui ont des casinos l'exemple
de la commune de ma collègue anne vantal
en vals les bains 3500 habitants ces
quatre cent mille euros de recettes en
moins par an imaginez comment un maire
peut monter dès lors un budget sans
avoir de lourdes conséquences à gérer
vous le voyez bien cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
l'importance de ce débat non pas pour
pointer du doigt parce que l'état a
justement demandé aux collectivités
d'être quelque part le bras armé d'être
celui
celle qui accompagne l'état dans la
crise mais aujourd'hui nous devons
évaluer au mieux l'ensemble de ceux
dépenses et je le dis de façon assez
exhaustive
parce que beaucoup de dépenses passe
inaperçue et il nous faut les pointes et
il faut que nous soyons finalement dans
une indemnisation comme je le disais au
réel et non pas au forfait
parce que pour ne parler que des centres
de vaccination il y a bien sûr le centre
de vaccination mais un autre exemple que
les communautés de communes de la
montagne ardéchoise 5000 habitants rien
que pour l'hébergement des personnes qui
font fonctionner le centre de
vaccination ces quelques vingt mille
euros
vous le voyez autant de sujets qui nous
inquiète et qui ne manqueront pas je le
sais d'animer ce débat aujourd'hui de
faire en sorte que les collègues qui
sont ici présents puisse illustrer mon
propos à travers va beaucoup d'autres
exemples pour encore une fois bien ciblé
le sujet et faire en sorte qu'il y ait
un juste accompagnement financier de
l'état enfin je voulais terminer par un
sujet qui me paraît essentiel l'état est
son plan de relance compte monsieur le
ministre sur les collectivités
singulièrement les communes dit au
passage que les départements et des
régions
elle aussi était des collectivités
particulièrement impacté mais s'agissant
des communes et de la commande publique
que j'évoquais il ne faudrait pas que
cette commande publique que ce plan de
relance soient mise à mal par ce que les
collectivités n'aurait pas au delà des
dotations et je le dis très clairement
l'état a fait en sorte qu'il y ait au
travers de la detr qu'il y ait au
travers de la des cils qu'il y ait au
travers de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement une prise en compte
mais faut-il parfois aller encore plus
loin pour vraiment prendre en compte
l'ensemble de ces coûts induits par la
crise pour qu'enfin les collectivités
puissent dès cette année 2021 être au
rendez-vous de la relance être
finalement c'est aiguillon dans cette
période de crise qui permettront à notre
pays de se relever alors voilà monsieur
le ministre nous comptons sur votre
sagacité votre pugnacité votre
détermination pour faire entendre la
voix de nos communes la voix de nos
collectivités
parce qu'une fine et nous ne voudrions
pas que les collectivités soient
vaccinés des promesses de l'état je vous
remercie
merci merci chers collègues de la
pertinence de votre intervention
j'invite maintenant monsieur joël giraud
secrétaire d'état chargé de la ruralité
s'exprimer pour une durée maximum
monsieur le ministre de huit minutes
bonjour bien madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis très heureux d'être aujourd'hui
parmi vous pour débattre du coût de la
crise pour les collectivités
territoriales et salua à mon tour leur
réactivité face à la crise c'est une
question vous savez qui est au coeur de
vos préoccupations puisque vous êtes la
chambre des territoires
c'est également une préoccupation
majeure du gouvernement j'ai conservé de
mes anciennes fonctions de maire tout
d'abord puis de rapporteur général du
budget à l'assemblée
l attachement tout particulier est ce
que le suivi des finances locales ne
fasse pas l'objet d'une attention
épisodique au gré de l'actualité mais
soit mené en permanence et en toute
transparence avec le parlement le débat
de ce jour me semble donc bienvenu
d'autant que nous disposons maintenant
d'un état quasi définitif des effets de
la crise sur les budgets locaux en 2020
et des premiers éléments sur 2021
il est intéressante donc que nous
puissions les partager je voudrais tout
d'abord vous confirmer que l'année 2020
elle a été certes difficile mais elle
n'a pas été l'annus horribilis que l'on
avait annoncé les collectivités dans
leur ensemble ont mieux résisté à la
crise que ce que nous imaginions
collectivement il ya un an
si je reprends les notes de conjoncture
dont nous disposions au milieu de
l'année dernière tout estimé que
l'impact financier de la crise serait
massif ainsi le rapport de jean rené
cazeneuve évaluer les conséquences à 5
milliards en recettes et 2,2 milliards
en dépenses en 2007 soit une diminution
de 7,2 milliards de lé par du brut pour
les collectivités en raison de la crise
ces hypothèses étaient fondées sur des
projections pessimistes sur un grand
nombre d'impôts locaux
à commencer par les droits de mutation à
titre onéreux dont on pensait alors
qu'il diminuerait de 25% par rapport à
en y ajoutant la dynamique des dépenses
ordinaires les parts du groupe des
collectivités auraient dû diminuer de
gênes 6% entre 2019 et 2020 est en
réalité l'exécution aux comptes avril
nous montre que les parts du brut des
collectivités diminuerait de 3,9
milliards d'euros soit un repli de 11 4%
entre deux exercices c'est peu au coût
deux fois mieux que nous ce qu'ils
escomptent dion et je crois que nous
devons tous nous en réjouir bien entendu
on observe des différences entre les
diverses catégories de collectivités
locales le bloc communal est celui qui a
le mieux résisté avec une et par du brut
en recul de 6 5%
cette tendance est bien marqué pour les
intercommunalités dans la capacité
d'autofinancement n'enregistre qu'une
diminution de 4,1 pour cent ainsi que
pour les petites communes celles de
moins de 3500 habitants voient même
globalement leur épargne augmenté de 2
4%
ce phénomène s'explique par des
économies de fonctionnement et par le
fait que les recettes de ces communes
sont largement composée de fiscalité
locale et de dotation qui sont
complètement imperméable à la crise les
départements constate pour leur part une
dégradation plus nette de la part du
brut de 14 % sous l'effet d'un
alourdissement des charges sociales en
revanche leurs recettes continuent de
progresser en 2020 en large partie grâce
au sco parce que les dm théo n'ont pas
autant diminué que prévu la baisse se
limite à 1,6 pour cent au final enfin
les régions perdent 21 6 % des parts du
brut du fait d'une progression
significative de leurs dépenses
d'intervention alors que leurs recettes
ont été relativement bien préservés
grâce aux garanties de l'état
ces résultats bien meilleurs qu'escompté
ont pu être obtenues grâce à des mesures
inédites que nous avons prises et qui
ont protégé les budgets locaux en
traitant leurs points de fragilité dès
le mois de juin 2020 tempé lait fer et
suite à la mission confiée à jean rené
cazeneuve nous avons mis en place la
clause de sauvegarde sur les recettes
fiscales et domaniale qui garantit à
chaque commune chaque intercommunalité
et aux syndicats de transport ou de
loisirs de percevoir une aide si le
montant de leurs recettes fiscales en
2008 pour mort de sa de la moyenne 2017
nous avons également mis en place dès
avant sur le produit tnt ou pour les
départements comme l'avait demandé
l'adf est milliards d'euros d'aidé s'ils
ont été ouverts en cours d'exercice pour
permettre aux nouvelles équipes
municipales de lancer des projets
d'investissement dé leur installation
sans attente 2021
et parallèlement nous avons ouvert aux
collectivités des facilités comptable
leur permettant d'étaler des changes via
la craie sur cinq budgets
j'ajoute que la loi de finances de 2021
a fait la part belle aux collectivités
locales notamment grâce aux accords du
débat parlementaire
nous avons reconduit le filet de
sécurité est garantie les fonds
départementaux de péréquation ddmt ou
pour les petites communes pour les
départements nous avons ouvert un fonds
de stabilisation de 200 millions d'euros
qui s'ajoutent aux 115 millions de 2007
et nous prévoyons de garantir leurs
fonds de péréquation à son niveau
habituel pour les régions nous avons
fait d'une pierre deux coups en
supprimant les cv lors cvae assad
épauler les entreprises
hier la remplaçant par une fraction de
tva ce qui leur permet d'être protégés
de la baisse de cvae qui est attendu en
en fait nous avons ouvert la ville 5
milliards d'euros de dotations
d'investissement de relance
supplémentaires dotation qui s'ajoute à
d'autres aides spécifiques bien été bien
entendu nous ne sommes pas au bout de la
crise et nos efforts doivent se
poursuivre ces efforts doivent être
guidés par quatre principes premiers
principes il faut suivre et vous avez
tout à fait raison de le préciser en
continu la situation financière des
collectivités locales et en rendre
compte au parlement
c'est un travail sur lequel mes services
que nous dirigions avec jacqueline
gourault ainsi que les services
d'olivier du sob sont mobilisés en
permanence un groupe de travail
spécifique a été constitué avec les
associations représentant le bloc
communal pour partager les données au
fur et à mesure il se réunit toutes les
six semaines environ et les comptes
rendus de réunions sont transmis aux
commissions des finances des deux
assemblées
deuxième principe il faut rassurer car
les perspectives pour 2021 sont loin
d'être sombre
selon les premières estimations les
recettes des collectivités devraient
augmenter en 2021
à notre connaissance les seuls produits
cisco qui devrait diminuer son la cvae
la taxe d'aménagement et la taxe sur les
remontées mécaniques
ce n'est pas rien mais c'est aussi très
rassurant car ça signifie que l'immense
majorité des recettes sont à l'abri
au demeurant les premières données sur
2021 sont rassurantes la cvae nous
devraient diminuer que de 1,1 pour cent
le versement mobilité a progressé de 3,8
pour cent sur le 1er trimestre et les dm
théo encaissés sur le premier trimestre
augmente de 10% par rapport au premier
trimestre 2009
troisième principe ne pas hésiter à
proposer des aides supplémentaires quand
la situation l'exigé
c'est ce que nous allons faire des de
même puisque le projet de loi de
finances rectificative va ouvrir un
fonds de 200 millions d'euros pour aider
les collectivités confrontées à des
pertes de recettes tarifaires ayant
entraîné des difficultés
et budgétaire c'est une aide et c'est
important qui concernera aussi bien les
services publics industriels et
commerciaux que les services publics
administratifs afin de couvrir un large
panel de situations quatrième principe
il faut rester vigilant sur l'exécution
de france relance nous avons dressé un
premier état des lieux début mai date à
laquelle 80% des dotations
d'investissement ouverte dans le plan de
relance était programmée ou notifiés par
les préfets nous vous rendons compte en
temps réel de l'actualisation de ce
chiffre
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs comme vous pouvez le
constater le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé pour s'assurer que le coût de
la crise pour les finances locales reste
soutenable et leur permettent d'investir
pour l'avenir du pays
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre dans la suite du débat chaque
orateur dispose de deux minutes maximum
pour présenter sa question avec une
réponse du gouvernement pour une durée
équivalente monsieur le ministre
j'y veillerai car nous avons un débat en
suivant dans le cas où l'auteur de la
question souhaite répliquer il dispose
de 30 secondes supplémentaires à la
seule condition que le temps initial de
deux minutes n'est pas été dépassé
j'invite monsieur daniel chacin a posé
sa question au nom des indépendants
madame la présidente monsieur mis mes
chers collègues depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
en mars 2000 nos finances publiques sont
prises en étau d'une pas en leur
ralentissement de l'activité économique
à évin provoqué une diminution des
recettes fiscales
d'autre part les mesures de soutien bien
sûr apprécié mais qui ont entraîné une
augmentation importante des dépenses
publiques c'est vrai bien sûr pour
l'état avec le soutien aux entreprises
aux salariés tout sanitaires le déficit
a dépassé les 200 milliards d'euros mais
aussi les difficultés se trouve au
niveau des collectivités locales et
notamment des services dont elles ont la
charge je veux évoquer ici le cas
particulier des lieux d'accueil pour
enfants gérées par les collectivités en
effet les recettes dépendent de leur
fréquentation
or la craie pendant la crise cette
fréquentation a baissé bien sûr ainsi
que les recettes qu'il s'agisse de la
partie
si passion des familles ou des aides de
la caf il en est de même par exemple
aussi de la cantine scolaire avec en
plus le service à table plutôt qu au
self
or dans le même temps les coûts des
ressources humaines sont restés les
mêmes élevé en effet même lorsque les
personnels étaient placés en
autorisations spéciales d'absences et
collectivités ont dû assumer la
continuité des charges salariales de
plus il y a eu un doublement des frais
d'entretien des locaux avec davantage
d'interventions et d'achats de produits
désinfection bien sûr rachat des masques
des pelouses organisation des
vaccinations alors il faut bien sûr
remercié les collectivités communes
départements qui ont effectué un travail
important nécessaire de proximité
pendant qu'on vide cela avec beaucoup de
dévouement
mais monsieur le ministre beaucoup
d'élus s'inquiète alors vous nous avez
rassuré un petit peu de s'inquiètent de
l'impact de cette situation sur les
finances publiques locales
quels sont les dispositifs nouveaux qui
peuvent permettre aux collectivités de
faire face à la baisse des recettes
d'une part et augmentation des recettes
d'autre part des dépenses d'autre part
pardon merci cher collègue monsieur le
ministre vous avez deux minutes pour
répondre merci mais la présidente
oui monsieur le sénateur chasse eh oui
comme je l'aï annoncé à l'instant le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui va être délibéré de mai en conseil
des ministres va comporter un dispositif
des aides au profit des communes et au
profil est en fait de leur des services
qui sont gérés en régie est confronté à
une baisse des recettes tarifaires en
2020 alors je rappelle qu'il s'agissait
des engagements qui avaient été pris par
le premier ministre au mois de mars et
sur lequel jacqueline gourault olivier
dussopt pts et moi même nous travaillons
depuis plusieurs semaines le constat que
nous avons fait à la fois celui d'une
baisse nette de la catégorie re de
recettes après recettes liées à la
fourniture de prestations de services à
caractère social périscolaire ou
culturelles de 30% en 2020 et pour le
bloc communal alors même que les
recettes de fonctionnement de diminue
que de 1 % au global dans ses recettes
sont assez localisé en fait il s'agit
d'un nombre limité de deux communes et
cela touche en particulier sur des
communes qui sont très peuplée avec
beaucoup d'équipements soit des petites
communes qui porte un équipement très
spécifiques par exemple
des termes centre thermoludique gérés en
régie ou un centre aqualudique
et s'agissant du dispositif lui-même je
tiens à préciser une chose c'est qu'il
s'agira d'une dotation budgétaire et non
d'un système d'avancés remboursables
le montant qui sera inscrit au budget je
voulais dit tout à l'heure s'élèvera à
200 millions d'euros ce qui je pense est
assez substantiel il sera décliné en
deux volets comme je vous l'avais
indiqué un premier volet qui va
compenser les services publics
industriels et commerciaux confondrait
une perte dépardieu brut en s'inspirant
de la logique de compensation qui avait
été retenu pour les entreprises privées
dont condé j'allais dire sur un système
d'équité un second volet qui consiste à
créer un fonds d'urgence au profit des
communes et des groupements raison de
leurs pertes de recettes tarifaires et
de leurs services publics administratifs
dans l'équilibré est fragilisée avec des
critères que nous devrons précisé dans
le débat parlementaire pour cible et
l'argent public sur les collectivités
qui connaissent de réelles difficultés
tarifaire je crois qu'il faudra bien
évidemment regarder comment se sont
comportés les recettes des services
scolaires les services de cantine ou
périscolaires que vous me signaler pour
voir comment les aider ces collectivités
placé en difficulté merci monsieur le
ministre j'ai invite maintenant monsieur
daniel salmon du groupe écologiste a
posé sa question
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues lorsque le
16 mars 2020 l'ensemble des structures
scolaires périscolaires et d'équipements
publics ont été amenés à fermer nombre
d'agents territoriaux ont été placés en
autorisations spéciales d'absence ou en
télétravail quand d'autres sont restés
en présentiel
beaucoup de collectivités ont eu du mal
à anticiper la gestion de leur personnel
lors de cette crise exceptionnelle
l'anc est nommé la crise sanitaire c'est
un impact en matière de gestion des
ressources humaines
réalisé par les associations de
collectivités a révélé que la majorité
des communes a subi un impact financier
significatif suite aux mesures
d'accompagnement prises en matière de
ressources humaines
les collectivités et établissements
publics ont démontré une véritable
capacité d'adaptation pour assurer leurs
missions de service public
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que
beaucoup d'argent territoriaux ont
fréquemment exercé des fonctions
inhabituelle par rapport à leurs cadres
d'emplois les collectivités ayant dû
intervenir dans des domaines
au delà de leur compétence habituelle
pour honorer cet engagement sans faille
un dispositif de primes pouvait être
instituée mais tous les agents n'ont pu
en bénéficier
toutes les collectivités ne pouvant se
le permettre
selon l'étude précitée 100 % des
communes de plus de 50 mille habitants
ont délibéré pour instituer une prime
contre seulement 23% des communes de
moins de 2000 habitants
vous en conviendrez il était difficile
pour ces petites communes à l' équilibre
budgétaire fragile de verser des primes
tout en supportant les surcoûts liés à
l'acquisition de matériel de protection
ou pour le télétravail au paiement des
heures supplémentaires à la prise en
charge du coût de remplacement des
agents placés en nasa ou encore celui
lié à l'élaboration d'un plan de
continuité d'activité la crise sanitaire
n'est pas encore derrière nous et
d'autres pourraient survenir
monsieur le ministre comment comptez
vous renforcer les moyens des
collectivités notamment des plus petites
afin de limiter les disparités entre les
agents territoriaux
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le sénateur seulement je voudrais
d'abord m'associer sur le sénateur à
l'hommage que vous rendez aux agents
publics qui n'ont pas ménagé leur peine
pendant cette crise et dont je suis moi
même le témoin puisque j'ai bénéficié
d'un centre de vaccination d'une
intercommunalité de cinq six mille
habitants
pour ce qui me concerne et pourrait
commencer les agents méritants
la loi de finances rectificative d'avril
2020 a prévu la possibilité d'attribuer
une prime exceptionnelle d'un montant
maximal de 1000 euros cette prime
s'adresse aux agents qui se sont
particulièrement mobilisés pour assurer
la continuité de l'activité de la
collectivité avec un surcroît de travail
que ce soit en présentiel ou l'entraidé
travail alors qu'on ferme en mai en eau
aux règles qui organise la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales
celle ci avait toute latitude pour fixer
le montant qu'elles souhaitaient
attribuer
bien entendu le coût de la prime et est
à la charge de l'employeur
je vois mal au demeurant quelle serait
l'alternative parce que nous n'allons
pas demander à un contribuable qui le
contribuable national de paye et des
décisions qui relèvent de gestion des
ressources humaines d'une collectivité
locale
d'ailleurs c'est une question qui se
pose en réalité depuis 1982 ce n'est pas
une question qui est spécifique à cette
crise
le constat que vous établissez que peu
les petites collectivités ont un recours
qui est moins important j'allais dire
ce système est un constat qui est opérée
sur le niveau des années mythiques droit
commun versée par les collectivités sur
leur taille depuis toujours
bon je ne crois pas pour autant qu'il
faille y mélanger les responsabilités
dans les décisions de politique
salariale
à noter toutefois que le législateur a
décidé d'exonérer la prime d'impôt sur
le revenu et de cotisations et de
contributions sociales ce qui représente
tout de même une économie pour les
employeurs territoriaux dont une partie
de la charge s'est retrouvé en fait
payés par l'état
merci c'est le ministre chapelle
maintenant monsieur monsieur salma vous
avez 30
merci madame le président c'est bien ce
qui me semblait merci monsieur ministre
pour votre réponse
effectivement mais on est un petit peu
là dans un petit fatalisme c'est à dire
qu'il reste une disparité entre les
entre les agents territoriaux mais bon
c'est vrai qu'il est pas facile de
lutter mais il faut il faut y réfléchir
mais cette période aura au moins permis
de souligner l'importance des services
publics ces derniers constituant une
force en tout temps et a fortiori en
période en période de crise il est
fondamental de conserver je dirais même
de fortifier la vigueur de notre service
public bien commun s'il en est à rebours
des politiques publiques actuelles merci
merci chers collègues
j'invite maintenant monsieur didier
rambaud du groupe du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes indépendant à
prendre la parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
en effet la réalité financière doit être
observé avec pragmatisme nos mandats de
parlementaire nous le rappellent les
collectivités locales ont fourni des
efforts colossaux de même que l'état et
les français
mais si cela a déjà été dit le coût de
la crise et particulièrement difficile
pour les collectivités territoriales de
notre pays
ce coup il l'est d'autant plus pour les
collectivités situées en montagne
en tant qu'élu du département d'isère
l'avenir de la montagne est un sujet qui
me tient que comme vous monsieur mini
s'imagine pour votre département des
hautes-alpes l'économie en montagne
était particulièrement affecté avec une
année blanche pour la saison hivernale
pourtant la montagne est un secteur clé
de la relance économique française
souvenons nous que le tourisme en
montagne représentent 20 milliards
d'euros de retombées économiques dont
10,5 milliards d'euros pour nos 350
stations de ski en pleine urgence le
gouvernement agit pour se tenir les
acteurs locaux plus de 5 milliards
d'euros ont été déployés durant la crise
mais les collectivités de montagne ont
plus que jamais besoin du soutien de
l'état
la semaine dernière le premier ministre
en savoie a annoncé le plan avenir
montagne avec ce plan concret et
prometteur le gouvernement entend
répondre aux attentes de ces territoires
dotations d'investissement contrat de
plan état région de massifs et soutient
l'ingénierie autant de dispositifs
concernés par les mesures de relance qui
s'élèvent à plus de 470 millions d'euros
pour soutenir nos singulier territoires
de montagne comme de nombreux élus de
ces collectivités
je suis convaincu que nous devons agir
pour leur redonner une impulsion et je
suis également convaincu que les acteurs
locaux seront tirer profit de ce plan à
venir montagne cela étant dit monsieur
le ministre j'ai deux interrogations
comment ces 481 millions d'euros seront
ils répartis entre les six régions
concernées et quel est le calendrier
envisagé pour leurs versements
merci merci cher collègue monsieur
ministre merci elle avait présidente
oui monsieur le sénateur cher didier
rambaud
alors votre question me donne l'occasion
de parler de ce grand problème qui est à
venir montagne que je veux saluer non
seulement parce qu'il répond vraiment
aux enjeux qu'affrontent les montagnards
aujourd'hui mais parce qu'il s'agit
aussi du premier plan d'investissement
pour la vente est depuis le plan neige
des années 1960
c'est donc vous le comprendrez avec
l'attachement particulier que vous
portez mais que je portais également à
la montagne que je tenais à le préciser
alors la semaine dernière le premier
ministre est effectivement d'abord
rappeler d'abord que 4 5 4 milliards
d'euros avaient été déployés en faveur
des territoires de montagne soit pour
gérer l'urgence ce soit pour mettre en
oeuvre la relance et aux scènes de ses 5
4 milliards d'euros 4 181 millions
d'euros était dédiée au soutien aux
collectivités locales de montagne
permettez moi de dire moi qui connais
bien quelques états étrangers ou le ski
existe aussi ce qui a pu se produire
dans les autres pays
on a souvent fait des remarques 1 au 10
ans les remontées sont ouvertes à un
endroit plutôt qu'un autre
à cela près que dans beaucoup de pays
d'europe les chômage partiel ça n'existe
pas et que les système d'anonymisation
aujourd'hui il n'y en a toujours pas
dans la plupart des pays qu'il s'agisse
de la suisse qu'il s'agisse de l'italie
qu'il s'agisse de l'autriche donc il
faut voir quand même il se faut savoir
raison garder au sein de l'espace
européen
simplement pour vous dire que sur ces
400 4
millions d'euros dédiés au soutien aux
collectivités locales il ya 36 millions
de garantie de recettes fiscales et
domine halle et domanial pardonnez-moi
de santé est de dotations
d'investissement france relance 242 pour
l'amendement des contrats de plan de
massif les cpu heures de massifs pour
être complet on peut rajouter aussi 38,5
millions d'euros de compensation qui
vont être versés directement aux rigides
remontée mécanique puisque vous le
saviez c'était une question importante
est que nous avons dû d'ailleurs
batailler avec bruxelles fort qu'il en
soit ainsi alors aujourd'hui les sur les
nouveaux crédits qui ont été mises en
oeuvre et qui vont qui ont été
développés par le premier ministre
l'autre jour 300 millions d'euros sont
dédiés à l'investissement à parité avec
les régions que je salue pour cet effort
considérable et 31 millions d'euros sont
dédiés à l'ingénierie dont ont besoin
les plus petits territoires pour deux
mais faire en sorte que cette montagne
de vienne résiliente
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
rambo j'invite donc monsieur christian
bilhac et du groupe rdse a posé sa
question pour deux minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre cheikh khaled les collectivités
territoriales ont pris leurs
responsabilités pendant cette crise
sanitaire
face à la pénurie de masques elles n'ont
pas ménagé leurs efforts pour
approvisionner la population
aujourd'hui elle contribue aussi en
partenariat avec l'état à l'organisation
du dépistage et à la vaccination à
grande échelle
enfin elle continue d'assurer les
services courants moyennant une
adaptation rapide mais coûteuse aux
contraintes imposées par les
restrictions sanitaires
toutes ces actions ont un coot et les
collectivités locales ont fait face à
des pertes inédite de recettes alors
même qu est entrée en vigueur la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des ménages sur l'association des
maires de france communes et
intercommunalités fut berrer 6 milliards
d'euros de pertes sur trois a lié à la
crise sanitaire pour les sabres et
collectivités territoriales le coût
devrait dépasser les 10 milliards ces
pertes ont été c'est vrai en contre
partie compensés dans le cadre des lois
de finances et beaucoup d'attentes
repose désormais sur l'atterrissage tous
les nations du plan de relance
si l'on en croit le ministre olivier
dussopt et vous même monsieur le
ministre l'avait souligné
les collectivités locales auraient été
les acteurs publics les plus résistants
budgétairement face à la crise par
rapport à l'état et la sécurité sociale
dans ces conditions le risque existe que
les collectivités soit une fois de plus
sollicités lorsque viendra le moment de
rembourser la dette qu'ovide le rapport
arthuis a proposé de pérenniser et
d'étendre le parc de cahors en
contradiction avec le principe de libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales
ce serait me semble-t-il un retour en
arrière de 40 ans un abandon des grands
principes des lois defferre de 1982
avez vous monsieur le ministre de suivre
les préconisations de monsieur arthuis
merci chers collègues mais ses ministres
merci le président le sénateur bihac la
lutte contre les conséquences de la
crise sanitaire a imposé une
augmentation massive des dépenses
publiques tentant par tandis qu'en
parallèle les recettes publiques
diminuer cet effort était indispensable
pour maintenir les emplois tissu
économique du pays
le besoin de financement qui en résulte
a été couvert pour une augmentation de
la dette dont le montant a progressé de
270 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui
cependant la production de sa tête est
très inégalement répartie entre les
différentes catégories d'administration
65 % de la dette supplémentaire a été
acquise par l'état 28 % par la sécurité
sociale et 7 % par les collectivités
locales et dans ses 7 % plus de la
moitié résulte en fait de l'endettement
de la société du grand paris autrement
dit les les collectivités elles mêmes
dans contact entre contracté pardonnez
moi que 8 5 milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire
il conviendra malgré tout de rembourser
cette dette que vite vous avez raison
tout comme les autres d'être pré
existante
or en la matière il n'existe pas de
solution miracle c'est pas un radical
que je dois le dire
d'ailleurs ça a été rappelé par la
commission des finances il y a une
dizaine de jours
nous l'avons dit nous n'augmenterons pas
les prélèvements obligatoires nous avons
deux solutions non exclusive pour faire
en sorte que les dépenses et augmente
moins vite que les recettes
stimuler notre croissance et donc nos
recettes et maîtriser notre dépense pas
plus que le rapport à tuer expose donc
avec les voies empruntées pour
stabiliser notre endettement
l'arrêt qui est proposée par jean a tué
elle a le mérite de la simplicité elle
consiste à poser le principe que les
dépenses augmentent tendanciellement
moins vite que les recettes
avec un objectif lui révèle de dépenses
pour cinq ans et en veillant à ne pas
dépasser ce plafond sur le quinquennat
je constate que plusieurs parlementaires
ont déposé des propositions de loi
organique qui prévoit des règles qui
ressemble d'ailleurs totalement à celle
ci une telle aguets et compatible avec
d'autres souhaits d'isoler une fraction
de la dette de l'état fin dû appliquer
un schéma d'amortissement spécifique en
l'occurrence le gouvernement a proposé
dans le programme de stabilité présenté
à la commission européenne d'amortir 140
milliards de dettes que vides au rythme
de la croissance c'est donc une
stratégie qui peut tout à fait être
appliquées par les collectivités sur
leur dette qui peuvent piloter leur
stratégie d endettement d'identifier une
fraction qui dessert la fraction de la
dette que vides cette identification est
facilitée d'ailleurs par la mise à
disposition des collectivités et parler
des collectivités d'un ex budgétaires
qui sont dédiés pour les comptes
administratifs 2020 2021 et 2022
la solution aujourd'hui préconise de
maîtriser la dépense locale en
s'inspirant des contrats le cahors je
crois que c'est un débat qu'il faut
certainement à voir mais c'est un débat
qui est un débat sain parce qu'il ne
faut pas que nous ayons une dette qui
dépasse la possibilité de notre pays que
ce soit des pour les collectivités
locales ou pour l'état
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur biya
que vous avez 37 secondes pour répliquer
oui très rapidement monsieur le ministre
est il ne faudrait pas demander aux
fourmis à ce que gérant fourmis les
collectivités locales de rapporter de la
sig à l'état merci chers collègues
j'invite maintenant monsieur pascal
savoldelli du groupe communiste a posé
sa question chère collègue madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
un constat ressort des travaux des
associations d'élus du sénat la mission
cazenove les collectivités subissent de
plein fouet la crise sanitaire
l'impact sur leurs budgets s'évalue à
plusieurs milliards d'euros sur
plusieurs années avec des pertes de
recettes et des hausses de dépenses
alimentant ce qu'on appelle un effet
ciseau les départements a subi une
hausse de 7 3% des dépenses sociales
liées au rsa jusqu'à 13% dans le
département du val de marne face aux
baisses de recettes leur capacité
d'autofinancement chute de 14% par
rapport à 2010 9 lors des lois de
finances rectificatives nous avons tenté
de sauver ce qu'il leur restait
d'autonomie dans notre proposition de
loi de soutien aux collectivités puis
dans la loi de finances pour 2021 avec 1
appuyez faisant d'elle les actrices de
la relance le gouvernement a préféré
apporter des solutions tardive laissant
les collectivités dans une position
précaire les départements sont exclus du
filet de sécurité déjà très limité du
bloc communal
le dispositif d'avancés remboursables
pour compenser les pertes des droits de
mutation est passé écoutez moi bien de
2,7 milliards d'euros à 119 millions
pourquoi ne pas avoir réorienté cet
argent vers les collectivités dans le
même temps les prêts garantis par l'état
atteignent 130 5 milliards d'euros le
coût pour les dépenses publiques
seraient au moins 2 6 milliards d'euros
cet argent bénéficiaient des entreprises
telles que renault qui a reçu près de 5
milliards d'euros
mais qu'est décidée sans concertation
avec les huttes fermer son usine de
choisy-le-roi en val de marne
monsieur le ministre comment justifier
une gabegie d'une telle ampleur
quand le gouvernement ne compense pas
correctement les 4 milliards de surcoûts
accusé par les collectivités pour 2021
allez vous corriger le tir enfin dans le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
présenté demain en conseil des ministres
merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur salsa vol délit les
départements n'ont pas été oubliés par
le gouvernement dans le cadre de la
crise sanitaire puisqu'ils ont également
bénéficié de mesures spécifiques par le
cadre de la loi de finances
rectificative de juillet 2020 elle
allait faire 3 et dans la loi de
finances pour 2020 tm la loi d'avoir
permis à chaque département qui en
faisaient la demande de bénéficier d'une
avance remboursable de l'état
remboursables sur trois ans si le
montant des droits de mutation à titre
onéreux en 2020 était inférieur à celui
perçu en moyenne entre 2017 et 2019
huit départements pourront une fille née
être bénéficiaire de cette avance pour
un montant de 119 millions d'euros
bien entendu nous avons provisionné
davantage mais c'était à l'époque où
nous pensions alors que les débats nte
diminuerait de 25 pour cent alors qu'au
final se sont repliées de 1 6% et ont
même augmenté dans deux tiers des
départements pour faire face à la
progression des allocations
individuelles de solidarité les lois de
finances de 2020 et 2021 ont maintenu ou
amplifier plusieurs dispositifs de
soutien exceptionnel d'une part la loi
de finances 2021 a maintenu le fonds de
stabilisation versé au département 2021
et l'augmentent même hauteur de 200
millions d'euros
d'autre part la loi de finances pour
2020 et autres au département chaque
année à compter de 1021 une fraction
dynamique de la tva de 250 millions
d'euros qui s'ajoutera à celle qui vient
en compensation de leur perte de taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties la
haute finance pour 2021 elle est aux
instituts une enveloppe de 300 millions
d'euros pour soutenir les
investissements des départements en
faveur de la rénovation thermique des
leurs bâtiments
l'ensemble de ces mesures traduit en
tout état de cause de l'ampleur du
soutien et de la tension qu'apporte le
gouvernement au département nous
conduirons bien sûr à travailler avec
les départements sur des questions
financières
jacqueline gourault et olivier dussopt
pts ont tenu une réunion avec l'adf il
ya deux semaines il a été convenu
d'étudier des améliorations possibles
des mécanisme de clause de sauvegarde
je veux parler des règles qui
permettrait de lisser les recettes
départementales afin d'approvisionner
une partie les bonnes années pour les
réinjecter sur les années plus
difficiles budgétairement quand vous le
voyez monsieur le sénateur nous sommes
depuis quatre ans les coûts des
départements et nous continuerons de
l'aide particulièrement cette période de
sortie de crise merci vous avez 50
secondes chers collègues pour répliquer
merci pour le bonus présidente istres
mais mes chers collègues
écoutez monsieur le ministre j'ai bien
je vous ai entendu égrainé les
dispositions que les prix pour les
départements mais si si tout le monde a
sorti sa calculette
vous avez à bout additionner quelques
centaines de millions mois soit c'est
moi qui suis un menteur et moi vous
savez ça me vexe pas comme le disent mes
formes donner des arguments dispositif
d'avancés remboursables pour compenser
les pertes de dmt haut
est-ce qu'il est bien passé monsieur le
ministre de 2,7 milliards d'euros à 119
millions moi je vous dis oui puisque
vous venez de le dire
vous l'avez reconnu donc comment il se
projette et départements et je dis ça
parce que la question est d'importance
on a quelques semaines d'un scrutin où
vous nous faites ici siéger évasif je te
passe des lois et des réformes les gens
vont voter beyala 4d et puis à la loi
rectificative
et puis là on va avoir en conseil des
ministres sérieusement je pense qu'il
faut pas s'étonner que les citoyennes et
les citoyens s'éloigne du politique
quand on les traite comme ça on leur dit
vous avez droit de voter ben on décidera
avant vous et droit de voter mon
décidera après chaque fait donc vite la
réponse était vraiment s'éloigner du bas
sont possibles sur les huit ans merci j
invite maintenant monsieur bernal
bernard delcros du groupe union
centriste a posé sa question
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministère collègue monsieur ministre dès
le début de la crise sanitaire
le gouvernement a pris les mesures qui
étaient nécessaires pour maintenir pays
debout sur les plans économique et
social puis dans un second temps à
partir du père et faire 2 juillet une
série de dispositions ont été adoptées
en faveur des collectivités locales mais
il demeure des angles morts des zones
non couvertes et je voudrais revenir sur
la question des régies qui est évoqué
parce que les mesures qui ont été prises
en 2020
on crée une disparité entre les
collectivités qui ont choisi de gérer
leur service à travers une dsp
auquel cas le délégataire a pu
bénéficier de toutes les aides en faveur
du secteur privé
mise en place par le gouvernement et les
collectivités qui ont fait le choix tout
à fait respectable par ailleurs de régie
et qui n'ont bénéficié d'aucune aide
cette situation devrait trouver une
réponse
vous l'avez rappelé dans le
l affaire que nous examinerons
rapidement et j'ai moi même participé au
groupe de travail qui étaient mis en
place par les ministères de la conel
territoire des comptes publics mais ma
question porte sur les critères qui
pourraient être retenus pour accompagner
les collectivités
parce que la fragilité d'une commune ou
d'une intercommunalité ne se mesure pas
au montant de la perte subie mais à la
part que représente cette perte dans les
recettes de fonctionnement de la
collectivité et donc de sa capacité à
l'assumer
par exemple une perte de seulement vingt
mille euros ou trente mille euros
consécutives à la fermeture d'un gîte
d'étape dans une petite commune on va
dire de montagne dont la recette fiscale
totale est inférieure à cent mille euros
peut placer cette collectivité en
difficulté et justifient que cette aide
que cette commune soient aidés alors
monsieur le ministre
seriez vous prêt à retenir comme l'un
des critères de compensation de la
fermeture des services gérés en régie la
perte de recettes de la collectivité
comparé à ses recettes de fonctionnement
autrement dit la perte de recettes
relatives de cette collectivité je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
merci madame brigitte oui monsieur le
sénateur cheikh bernard delcros bon je
voulais annoncé donc je ne vais pas
revenir là dessus il y aura
effectivement 200 millions d'euros qui
sont prévus dans le plfr qui va être
délibéré dès demain en conseil des
ministres et c'est vrai que c'était un
travail qui a été important parce que
c'est le travail où il fallait que nous
arriverons à trouver des solutions pour
l'ensemble j'allais dire des modes de
gestion des collectivités alors dans le
plan à venir montagne dont on parlait
tout à l'heure nous l'avons trouvé avec
des notifications la commission
européenne concernant des régies qui
étaient des régies de remontées
mécaniques qu'il s'agissait d'un
phénomène très spécifique et j'allais
dire très très massif pour autant il
fallait trouver des solutions pour
l'ensemble des délégués de ce que vous
savez à quoi vous faites allusion c'est
à dire que par exemple un gîte communal
qui perd des recettes bien évidemment si
ces recettes sont significatives par
rapport au budget c'est votre question
il rentrera dans une logique qui sera
une logique de compensation
donc on est vraiment sur la logique que
vous décrivez à l'instant à la fois pour
les services qui sont les services
publics industriels et commerciaux mais
également pour les services publics
administratifs
sachant que aussi il arrive que les
nomenclatures comptable n'est pas
forcément homogène d'un département à un
autre donc
comprendrez que c'était un travail qui
est particulièrement complet s'il va
être confiée au défi mais soyez rassurés
sur une chose c'est que sur sur ces
histoires de perdre tarifaire on avait
été déjà un certain nombre j'étais
parlementaire à l'époque attiré
l'attention du gouvernement sur les
risques ce qui allait perdurer si la
crise perdure et nous ne le savions pas
à l'époque ce qui allait se passer
en terme de hre confinement en terme de
hre fermeture d'un certain nombre
d'établissements en termes de maintien
longue des fermetures aujourd'hui comme
je le disais tout à l'heure nous avons
la réalité des chiffres qui peuvent être
produits à ce bémol effectivement qu'il
faut regarder de très près les chiffres
parce que c'est pas toujours des prises
en compte comptables qui sont j'irai
comparables vous avez raison de
souligner que ce sont les collectivités
les plus fragiles qui souvent ont mis
leurs services non pas en dsp mais en
régie parce que ça n'intéressait pas un
opérateur privé que de gérer un certain
nombre de services donc tout cela est
bien prise en compte
le fonds de 200 millions d'euros qui
sera dans le plfr qui va être délibéré
de même merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur da cruz avec 43 secondes
bon je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre cette réponse qui qui va dans
le sens souhaité parce que vous l'avez
rappelé
globalement les petites communes ont
plutôt bien résisté à la crise d'une
façon globale et en moyenne c'est une
réalité mais il ya des disparités très
fortes y compris à l'intérieur d'une
strate de collectivités en tous les cas
je vous remercie de votre réponse
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent monsieur jérôme durain du groupe
des socialistes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre
chers collègues cette séance est pour
moi l'occasion d'évoquer un des échelons
les plus touchées par l'impact de la
crise l'échelon régional comme bourgogne
franche comté je reviendrai sur les
pertes de ressources constaté par notre
région et je m'interrogerais je vous
interrogerait sur les compensations
apportées par l'état
la crise c'est d'abord des dépenses en
plus et la région bourgogne franche
comté comme d'autres à jouer son rôle
pour accompagner nos concitoyens sur
notre territoire
nous avons d'ailleurs parfois été trop
efficace puisqu'il est arrivé par
exemple que l'état réquisitionne aux
commandes de masques sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de bâle mulhouse
mais notre action ne s'est pas limité à
cette urgence nous avons aussi déployer
comme d'autres régions des dispositifs
de soutien économique d'envergure 36
millions pour les commerçants artisans
tpe 12 millions pour les structures de
l'événementiel de la culture les acteurs
du tourisme 10 millions d'euros pour les
équipements dans les hôpitaux une aide
financière aux indemnités de stage pour
les élèves aides soignants et infirmiers
5 millions pour les associations 4
millions pour les étudiants ce sont des
choix politiques qui ont été différents
selon les régions
mais c'est aussi une nécessité en
réponse à la crise au total ce sont 5
140 millions d' aides que nous avons
voté parfois d'ailleurs en complément
des aides d'état pour soutenir la
reprise économique et les emplois
mais la crise c'est surtout des recettes
en moins chers collègues dans vos
régions aussi l'exploitation ferroviaire
notamment a été logiquement bouleversé
par la crise avec une fréquentation
réduite de moitié et c'est là que les
choses se gâtent puisque les recettes
sont passées dans d'autres régions par
exemple logiquement de 83 millions
d'euros à 40 millions d'euros et même en
réduisant de trafic de 25% nous n'avons
pas pu réduire nos dépenses ou seulement
de quelques pourcents 5,6 notamment en
raison de la stabilité des charges
d'amortissement du matériel et des frais
de personnel et la situation est même
plus grave en 2021 qu'en 2020 puisqu'à
l'époque on avait réduit notre plan de
transport 2 90%
ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre quelles compensations de l'état
sur ce volet les agglomérations qui
touchait le versement transport ont
elles pu bénéficier de compensation par
l'état
qu'en est-il des collectivités
régionales merci chers collègues le
ministre
merci mais la présidente oui monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur donc je ne vais je
vais à la fois tenté de répondre à votre
question mais également de vous donner
un peu une j'irai un éclairage
d'ensemble sur l'ensemble de votre
région qui est bourgogne franche comté
bon tout d'abord concernant les régions
je vous le rappelle enfin il ya quand
même un certain nombre de garanties qui
ont été mis en place par exemple le
switch tva cvae que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure dans mon propos liminaire a
permis de faire en sorte que didier 215
millions d'euros au niveau national de
nos pertes pour les collectivités
régionales
il ya aussi la garantie relative aux
recettes de tva de cécité de thé icpe
bon qui a été mise en place il ya au
delà
quelque chose qui me semble extrêmement
important qui la création de cette
dotation régionale d'investissement
ces 600 millions d'euros dont 25
millions d'euros pour votre propre
région donc ça fait partie des mesures
importantes qu'il me semble ont été
prises en compte par le gouvernement
pour vos régions mais si on veut
regarder de manière plus générale si
c'est passé en bourgogne franche comté
sept cent quarante et une communes de
votre région ont reçu des compensations
de 5,1 millions d'euros sur leurs
recettes fiscales et domanial c'est une
aide aussi qui vient combler la totalité
de l'écart entre les recettes fiscales
et domanial entre 2020 et la moyenne de
référence
je situe pas des des communes comme
chalon ou comme bourbon lancy qui ont
reçu 160 mille euros ça me semble assez
important et un chiffre significatif
concernant les impôts m
une d'entre elles a reçu une
compensation fiscale face à une baisse
importante de son versement mobilité et
5 en sus des avances remboursables pour
21 milliards d'euros par ailleurs les
collectivités de la région vont recevoir
ou ont déjà reçu une notification de 117
millions d'euros de dotation de relance
qui viennent s'ajouter aux moyens
ordinaires comme comme la d 6 et 25
millions d'euros par an dans votre dans
votre région bon l'histoire ne s'arrête
pas là je viens de le dire puisque au
delà de cela les aide complémentaire
pour arriver pour certaines régies qui
sont en difficulté financière donc
s'agissant des web nous avons confié de
plus une
une mission à philippe duron de façon à
faire un point le rapport va être rendue
au mode joueuses qui ne vous permettra
d'ajuster les choses donc voyez monsieur
le monsieur le sénateur au delà de la
collectivité régionale qui a bénéficié
d'un certain nombre de compensation
c'est l'ensemble d'un territoire parce
que je crois qu'il faut voir la
globalité des territoires qui
aujourd'hui en bourgogne franche comté
bénéficié à bénéficier d'un système qui
est un système particulièrement là
encore résilié en termes de
compensations merci monsieur le ministre
madame alexandra banquiers au fond de
teint pour les républicains
vous avez deux minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il est
acquis que cette crise sanitaire a
enfanté une crise économique qui
n'épargne ni les finances locales ni les
finances publiques ce débat essentiel
pour nos élus locaux et initié par le
groupe les républicains montrent bien
finalement l'intérêt irréductibles
portés par nos membres aux enjeux avec
en éolien nos territoires les
collectivités ont affronté vous le savez
cette crise avec dynamisme ne lésinant
pas sur les dépenses afin de satisfaire
aux besoins nécessaires exprimé par
leurs administrés et pas uniquement
leurs habitants soignants enseignants
commerçants tous ont bénéficié bénéficie
encore de leur aide
et ce depuis le début de la crise les
dépenses sont estimées par l'association
des maires et présidents
d'intercommunalités de france environ 6
milliards d'euros l'état avait pourtant
annoncé le soutien financier des
collectivités locales un plan
d'accompagnement qui devait être massif
extrêmement ambitieux et toucher entre
12000 et 14000 communes et
intercommunalités au final 2300 à 2500
commune et une centaine de pci sont
concernées avec un plafond nettement
diminué les collectivités monsieur le
ministre ressorte exténué le budget de
la plupart épuisé la mf redoutent que la
baisse de recettes tarifaires soit
compensée par une hausse de la taxe
foncière car c'est un des seul levier
finalement dont les collectivités
territoriales disposent pour compenser
cette situation une fois de plus l'état
fait porter la responsabilité de
l'augmentation de la pression fiscale
aux collectivités en n'assumant pas
jusqu'au bout les missions qui lui
incombent
et ce n'est pas aux contribuables de
payer cette facture le gouvernement ne
cesse de se retrancher derrière un
argument qui consiste à répondre aux
élus que des économies ont été faites en
raison du ralentissement de certaines
activités c'est vrai par exemple dans ma
commune à antibes juan les pins ces
économies représentent un million et
demi d'euros
mais faisons preuve de rigueur et
surtout de sincérité les pertes de
recettes de la ville sont estimés à 9
millions et demi d'euros et des dépenses
supplémentaires à hauteur de 2 millions
d'euros se sont imposés vous convient
vous conviendrez que malgré ses
économies
il déplore dont près de 10 millions
d'euros de perte nette s'est 5% du
budget de la commune n'ont pas de
compensation ma question est simple
pourquoi refusez vous de compenser les
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
afin qu'elles puissent continuer de
s'investir dans cette crise sanitaire et
économique que le pays traverse
merci cher collègue monsieur ministre
merci mais la présidente
oui madame la sénatrice j'aurais pu vous
donner des chiffres très précis si
j'avais su la la thématique générale que
vous souhaitiez abordés de même des
chiffres encore plus précis sur le
département des alpes-maritimes et les
différentes collectivités qui le
composent mais reconnaissez une chose
c'est que effectivement lorsque l'on
veut compenser notamment
je pense en particulier aux pertes
tarifaires mais pas que il faut avoir
une vision claire de ce qui a été
l'équilibré des recettes et des dépenses
est un peu la même question que que
votre collègue sénateur concernant les
départements
lorsque vous provisionné de l'argent qui
vous posez provisionné 2 7 milliards
d'euros en vous disant il va y avoir un
effondrement ddm p o
eh bien là quand la réalité est tout
autre et que finalement on arrive avec
des situations dans un certain nombre de
départements
il y a eu au contraire une augmentation
de dmt au vous comprenez bien que il n'y
a pas beaucoup de choses à commencer
s'agissant des collectivités locales je
lisais je suis dit extrêmement conscient
de l'effort qui a été celui des
collectivités locales qu'il s'agisse des
communes qu'ils s'agissent des
intercommunalités également sur le plan
tout simplement de l'accompagnement des
personnes nous sommes aujourd'hui
depuis le 30 avril en mesure de faire un
bilan que j'indiquais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que nous voyons la réalité
de l'effort conjoint que doit mener
l'état et les collectivités locales
parce que lorsqu'il ya une crise il y
avait dans cette crise il avait toujours
une proportionnalité entre les
différentes collectivités
je le disais tout à l'heure la part
prise par la de la dette de la part de
l'état est une extrêmement importante
j'écoute est là encore très discrètement
quelqu'un qui disait que ma foi les
l'état n'avait pas été vertueux mais je
pense que si l'état avait été vertueux
il y aurait beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils n'auraient plus du tout d'emplois
alors on est alors je demandais quelques
chiffres dans dans le dans le zéro dans
le département des alpes maritimes c'est
à dire dans le 06 pendant des mois j'ai
l'habitude d'utiliser les chiffres on a
14 millions d'euros de compensation par
le département des alpes maritimes dont
11 bis ses 91 millions d'euros 9 je vois
mal 9 millions d'euros pour cela qu'une
collectivité qui la commune de cad
donc vous voyez bien que dans cette
affaire-là le l'état franchement joué
son rôle et continuera à le jouer grâce
aux plfr qu' il va être délibéré demain
s'agissant des problématiques de régime
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à présent messieurs
jean-marie misons du groupe union
centriste merci mme la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
sans surprise le coût de la pandémie que
notre pays vient d'essuyer
particulièrement lourd pour nos finances
locales
avant toute chose il convient de
souligner ici la réactivité remarquable
de nos collectivités face à une épidémie
de la soudaineté et la violence sont
sans égal dans l'histoire il nous faut
également rendre hommage à leurs élus et
leurs personnels qui ont pris en charge
l'organisation de l'accès aux soins et
la chaîne la distribution d'équipements
de protection ils ont également tenté de
pallier les effets de la fracture
numérique assure en coûte que coûte la
continuité du service public
ils ont surtout innover comme dans le
grand est qui a créé le fonds résistance
mobilisant 4,44 millions d'euros afin de
soutenir l'économie locale nos
collectivités ont pour cela engager des
dépenses exceptionnelles consistante
pour l'essentiel en la rémunération des
personnels remplaçants ou encore au
versement des primes exceptionnelles
comme celles attribuées aux aides à
domicile tout dépend ce que les
économies réalisées sur certains postes
tels que les frais de déplacement de
restructurer de restauration de
formation encore la non reconduction de
certains contrats non compensés qu'en
partie
par conséquent même si aujourd'hui tout
n'est pas noir il apparaît clairement
que l'état doit combler les déficits
entraînés par ces différentes opérations
que les collectivités territoriales sol
ne peuvent supporter aussi
pouvez vous nous indiquer ce que le
gouvernement entend faire pour leur
fournir toute l'aide financière dont
elles ont besoin en particulier pour ce
qui est de la compensation des pertes de
recettes tarifaires y compris pour les
opci compétent en matière de mobilité
qui exploite des services de transport
en commun même si j'ai bien compris
monsieur le ministre
l'ouverture tardive mais réelle du
gouvernement sur ce sujet merci chers
collègues le ministre
oui merci madame présidente oui monsieur
le sénateur misons moi je salue
également l'implication des
collectivités et notamment des conseils
régionaux de à la fois dans l'appui aux
entreprises mais également dans d'autres
dispositifs suscité tout à l'heure le
dispositif à venir montaigne ou l'adf et
l'ensemble des régions concernées ont
été proactif pour faire en sorte que
pour un euro investi il y ait de la part
de l'état il ya un euro investi de la
part des régions
vous avez cité le fond en résistance qui
est mise en oeuvre par la région grand
est
c'est un très bon exemple de l'agilité
des collectivités pour réagir en cas de
difficultés mais je souhaite aussi
rappeler que l'état n'a pas été moins
agile et à jouer tout son rôle parce que
d'abord vis-à-vis des entreprises en
grand test
alors pour vous parler pour donner des
chiffres locaux nous avons déjà versé 1
8 milliard d'euros au titre du fonds de
solidarité mais aussi garanti 8
milliards d'euros de prêts aux
entreprises voyez que démentent ces
montants sont quand même très très
massif ensuite vis-à-vis des
collectivités 439 communes et 13 pci de
votre région ont reçu une compensation
de 4,3 millions d'euros sur leurs
recettes fiscales et domanial c'était
devient d'ailleurs combler la totalité
de l'écart entre les recettes fiscales
et domanial entre 2020 et la moyenne de
référence dans votre département par
exemple la métropole de metz a reçu 1,2
million d'euros
concernant les impôts m quatre d'entre
elles sont déjà reçu une compensation
fiscale face sur une baisse très
importante du versement mobilité et 14
ont reçu des avances remboursables pour
30 millions d'euros
par ailleurs les collectivités de la
région vont recevoir ou ont déjà reçu
notification de 224 millions d'euros de
dotation de relance qui viennent
s'ajouter aux moyens ordinaires comme la
d6 c'est à dire 50 millions d'euros par
an dans votre région bien sûr je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure l'histoire ne
s'arrête pas là jeudi à votre collègue
sénatrice
j'ai déjà rappelé que des aides
complémentaires harry fort notamment les
problématiques des régies en difficulté
financière et je le répète s'agissait à
la fois des speak et des spas pour que
les choses soient vraiment très claire
de ce côté là puisqu'il y avait quelques
inquiétudes que je comprends aisément
ayant été maire pendant 27 ans et
s'agissant des eaux m
je le dis je le répète compte tenu des
ouvertures que s'ils ont été faites et
notamment le rapport que philippe durand
beau nous remettre d'ici au mois de juin
de façon à ce que les choses puissent
être le mieux cadrer possible
si monsieur le ministre monsieur maison
vous avez 50 secondes merci vais dans la
précédente j'ai eu peur tout monsieur le
ministre
lorsque tout à l'heure vous iger dans
les veaux propos liminaire que les
recettes des collectivités se porte pas
si mal que cela j'ai eu peur que vous
disiez que vous rajoutiez que c'était
grâce à l'augmentation de la dgf nous
aurait eu un humour à décaper tout le
monde
deuxième observation c'est comme les 200
millions que vous évoquez vont sont très
loin du compte puisque les collectivités
leurs associations nationales sont sur
des montants bien supérieurs qui dépasse
les deux milliards d'euros
je ne sais pas comment vous arrivez aux
200 millions mais sachez que du côté des
associations d'élus notamment de la mvw
on est plutôt sur une montant de 2,2 de
dix fois plus dix fois supérieure et
enfin j'insiste sur la mobilité sur les
régies c'est pas la même chose d'avoir
une avance que d'avoir une dotation
j'espère que vous trouverez les voies et
moyens pour compenser je crois à votre
bonne foi
justement c'est ces opérateurs qui les
mérite fortement merci merci chers
collègues je passe la parole à présent
un monsieur jean-michel houlgate du
groupe socialiste monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues en ce mois de juin
qui commence on ne peut évidemment pas
s'empêcher de penser à la prochaine
saison touristique qui s'engage or si
les perspectives sont plutôt positives
en terme de fréquentation
bon nombre de collectivités sont
inquiètes car le tourisme c'est une
multitude d'acteurs privés associatifs
et publics qui sont en grande difficulté
les offices de tourisme sont fortement
fragilisé par la crise d'une part seuls
les offices qui sont subventionnées à
moins de 50% ont pu bénéficier du
chômage partiel
d'autre part la taxe de séjour qui a été
une recette extrêmement dynamique entre
2012 et 2019 puisqu'elle est passé de
239 millions d'euros à 503 millions
durant cette période devrait une fois
les comptes administratifs consolidé ont
enregistré une baisse qui va parfois
pour certaines communes jusqu'à 40%
or la taxe de séjour elle transite elle
par les budgets des collectivités et la
compensation de
à perte est liée à la situation
budgétaire des recettes fiscales et de
manial des différents des derniers
exercices de l'ensemble de cette
collectivité
il peut s'avérer et c'est vrai qu'une
collectivité qui a eu des fortes
dépenses liées aux surcoûts de la crise
n'ai reçu aucune compensation
car ces recettes se sont globalement
maintenues les recettes fiscales et
domanial alors que celle recettes fléché
destinés à être reversés à l'office du
tourisme se sont elles effondrées sur le
ministre
cette situation ne mérite t elle pas une
attention particulière est ce que vous
pouvez nous confirmer alors que la
compensation aux épique de tourisme
figure bien dans le plfr qui sera
examiné demain en conseil des ministres
de même et et cela dans un tout autre
domaine pouvez vous me confirmer que les
communes qui possèdent un casino souvent
très modestes mais dont l'importance des
revenus de la taxe sur les jeux est
vital pour le budget communal ont bien
été cette fois-ci l'objet d'une
compensation intégrale
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci la présidente oui monsieur le
sénateur houlgate
vous avez parfaitement raison de
souligner que les communes touristiques
font partie des plus affectés par la
crise sanitaire bien évidemment c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons bien
entendu décidé de compenser et
d'intégrer dans les mécanismes de
compensation les recettes perçues par
ces communes je pense d'abord la taxe de
séjour mais aussi aux produits des jeux
dans les communes qui accueillent des
casinos
je précise d'ailleurs que la taxe de
séjour et compenser sur une base qui est
une base 2019 en raison des modalités
d'évolution de perception de la taxe
je me rappelle pour bien avoir porté
sept ans lorsque j'étais rapporteur
général à l'assemblée nationale parce
qu'effectivement ça se fait par rapport
à une moyenne et une moyenne qui ne
représentaient pas la réalité du
dynamisme à la fois nous avions et
l'argile à la base avec un certaine
nombre j'allais dire de deux
contribuables supplémentaires qui ne
paient pas toujours la taxe de séjour
notamment dans les quêtes en région très
touristique et mais il avait également
la problématique de la montée en
puissance de beaucoup de terres
communales it et sur ce sujet donc c'est
bien cet amendement qui a permis
aujourd'hui peut-être sur une base qui
est une base à mon avis beaucoup plus
intéressante celle qui aurait été le
la base initialement prévue de la
moyenne de 2010 est à 2019
alors maintenant si on regarde les
résultats on constate que 77 millions
d'euros de dotations sur les 200 sont
allés à des communes classées sasson de
tourisme ou de la moitié des communes
ont été
accueillis dans un casino ont bénéficié
de la dotation pour un montant de 62
millions d'euros dans votre région je
peux citer deauville bagnoles de l'orne
mais également ouistreham ou encore
trouville jeu si dell pour être tout à
fait complet que la commune de cherbourg
en cotentin n'est pas éligible
en effet ces produits fiscaux de 2020
dépasse de 1 million de roses les mêmes
produits entre 2017 et 2019 donc de ce
fait on ne sommes pas dans une situation
de perte
en ce qui concerne les offices de
tourisme en règle générale ceux ci
perçoivent une partie de la taxe de
séjour qui reversait par la commune
dans ce cas la compensation se fait au
niveau de la commune et il n'y a pas de
problème car l'office de tourisme et je
comprends que c'est votre question
perçoit directement la taxe qui est un
cas assez rare mais qui existe il n'y a
pas de compensation à ce stade mais le
mécanisme de compensation des speed que
nous allons prévu que nous avons prévu
dans le plfr qui sera discutée donc dans
quelques jours va apporter une réponse à
aux offices de tourisme dont les parts
du brut se serait dégradée fortement
donc ce sera par ce biais qu'il y aura
réintégration j'allais dire de ces
pertes
merci monsieur le maire vous avez 35
secondes
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse on voit que le filet de sécurité
est à largement mallet et comme le dit
madame gouro il faut faire du cousu main
donc ce qu'on vous demande tout
simplement c'est de sortir le filet à
crevettes pour pouvoir utiliser les cas
particuliers et il y en a beaucoup et à
travers les exemples qui nous sont
représentés aujourd'hui vous rendez
compte qu'il ya beaucoup de situations à
régler merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent monsieur bernard
fournier du groupe l'est républicain
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il est très
difficile d'avoir une analyse globale
sur le coût économique pour les
collectivités de la crise de la queue
vide 19 tellement les situations dans le
commune sont hétérogènes dans le temps
qui m'est imparti
je voudrais m'attarder sur la situation
des communes rurales en effet ces
dernières ont été particulièrement
touchés lorsqu'elle dispose d'une école
ou de structures d'accueil de loisirs
l'impact des protocoles sanitaires sur
les dépenses de fonctionnement
ressources humaines a été très important
pour certaines d'entre elles nous
pouvons aussi évoqué le cas des communes
rurales touristique qui n'ont pu que
constater la baisse substantielle de
leurs recettes de produits
d'exploitation les communes qui est loin
des équipements n'ont pas été épargnés
non plus même si nous ne pouvons que
saluer l'ensemble des mesures de soutien
de l'état aux collectivités elles
restent encore insuffisantes pour le
moment une des manières les plus
efficaces pour les aider à sortir le
plus rapidement de la crise sanitaire
résidents l'aide que l'état pourrait
apporter à leurs projets
d'investissements investissement qui
profiterait à irriguer les entreprises
de nos territoires et participerait à la
relance de l'économie française
cependant les élus des petites communes
sont souvent découragés par la
complexité et la quantité des
dispositifs qui sont proposés lors des
différents appels à projets dans le
cadre des dotations d'investissement
il ne dispose pas de l'ingénierie
nécessaire afin de monter les dossiers
après un an de mandat et alors qu'est la
france ceux des confine progressivement
il est primordial que l'état soit au
côté les élus des territoires ruraux
pour participer à la relance de notre
économie
aussi je souhaiterais que vous nous
préciser monsieur le ministre les
financements que le gouvernement a mis
en place pour soutenir la relance de
l'investissement des communes rurales et
simplifier leurs démarches
je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci mais la présidente
oui monsieur le sénateur fournier vous
m'interrogez plus spécifiquement sur le
soutien de l'état à l'investissement des
collectivités les plus rurales
alors je voudrais a insisté sur trois
points d'abord l'accroissement du
soutien à l'investissement local dans le
cadre du plan de relance avec la
majoration de 950 millions d'euros de
l'adsl qui a été votée l'été dernier et
qui est destiné à financer des projets
s'inscrivant dans la transition
écologique la résidence sanitaires et la
préservation du patrimoine
nous avons veillé dans les circulaires
d'application avec jacqueline gourault à
ce que les choses soient très claires
vis-à-vis des préfets de région sur la
possibilité de cumuler des auteurs et
des cils ce qui permet à des communes
rurales d'en bénéficier et j'inaugure
pas mal de lieux qui s'étend des
communes très rurale qui correspondent à
ceux là l'enveloppent également de qui a
été voté en loi de finances pour 2021
afin de financer les travaux de
rénovation énergétique pour les
bâtiments des collectivités dont 650
millions d'euros sont faux destinés au
bloc communal gérer de manière analogue
à l'adsl
jacqueline gourault nous avons demandé
donc aux préfets d'être vigilant l'
équilibre territorial les suivants sur
ans les centres davantage de temps aux
communes rurales qui aurait besoin pour
déposer leur dossier puisque nous
comprenons bien les problèmes
d'ingénierie dans les communes rurales
par les aidants les constitué si besoin
quel rôle des sous préfet territoriaux
lors dans votre département la loire 41
projets communaux ont d'ores et déjà été
financés en 2020 avec cette tranche de
dsi l or 25 projets sur ces 41 ans
emporté par des communes rurales
ensuite nous mobilisant des moyens
exceptionnels en ingénierie c'est là le
sujet que vous évoquez qu'il semble
extrêmement important
je vous rappelle parce que je crois
qu'il faut toujours insister là dessus
que les marchés l'ingénierie de la nctc
20 millions d'euros en 2021 sont
gratuits pour l'ensemble des communes de
moins de 3500 habitants et les opci de
moins de 15000 habitants
donc sur ce marché et ses marchés
d'ingénierie vous pouvez émargé de
manière gratuite ont par ailleurs il ya
tout un système avec les programmes
nationaux vous avez quelques fois des
petites villes de demain par exemple qui
sont très petit dans un certain nombre
de départements nous descendons jusqu'à
200 habitants sur des bourgs centres en
difficulté donc c'est quand même une
femme très important où il ya beaucoup
d'ingénierie ingénierie qu'il doit être
partagée avec les autres communes au
sein de l'intercommunalité de façon à ce
que tout le territoire soit couvert
il y a aussi des programmes nationaux
qui sont importants et enfin vous
mentionner les
les écoles et les structures d'accueil
sur ce point je je vous confirme ce que
je disais aux sénateurs chassaing à
savoir que nous allons regarder de près
cette question dans le cadre des
compensations de recettes tarifaires
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à présent à notre collègue hussein
bourgi du groupe socialiste madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues la crise sanitaire a eu
un impact direct sur les finances des
collectivités locales impacts directs en
raison des dépenses exceptionnelles et
des pertes de recettes occasionnés par
la coved 19 et les confinements
successifs il y à aussi l'impact
indirect de la crise sanitaire sur les
collectivités territoriales
je veux évoquer les difficultés que
rencontrent de nombreuses associations
sportives culturelles de loisirs nos
clubs sportifs ont perdu monsieur le
ministre une part importante de leurs
licenciés nos écoles de musique de danse
ont perdu une part significative de
leurs adhérents
certaines organisations qui chaque été
et tout au long de l'année organisé les
manifestations culturelles des festivals
en particulier sont aujourd'hui en
sursis
bref nos associations ont vu leur
trésorerie fortement dégradé
plus de trente mille d'entre elles ne
survivront pas à la crise des dizaines
de milliers d'autres sont en très grande
difficulté et singulièrement depuis le
second confinement les mesures
gouvernementales que nous avons salué
ont prioritairement concerner les
associations ayant des salariés avec le
chômage partiel par exemple
mais les associations constituées
exclusivement de bénévoles sont restés
dans un angle mort peu ou pas dead leur
sont destinés celle ci se tournent
aujourd'hui vers les communes les
intercommunalités les départements les
régions pour leur demander des
subventions exceptionnelles pour
renflouer leur budget et honorer leurs
charges courantes
c'est un cruel dilemne auxquels sont
confrontés les élus locaux en aidant ces
associations ils alourdissent la facture
déjà lourde et longue de la crise
sanitaire pour les collectivités
monsieur le ministre
de quelle manière le gouvernement
peut-il aider les collectivités
territoriales et singulièrement les
communes rurales a sauvé les
associations qui créent le lien social
et contribue à l'attractivité de nos
territoires
quelles mesures spécifiques dédiés à ces
associations le gouvernement compte-t-il
mettre en oeuvre je vous remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre merci madame oui monsieur le
sénateur bourgi alors il ya deux choses
dans votre question il ya d'abord la
situation j'allais dire des
collectivités locales et donc leur
capacité à pouvoir financer des
associations
je viens je dirais de répondre à un
certain nombre de sujets notamment à la
problématique des pertes de recettes
tarifaires qui est évidemment une
problématique centrale et qui a fait que
certaines collectivités attendait même
même pour élaborer leur budget de savoir
j'allais dire à quelle sauce ils
allaient être mangés pour autant ce que
je vienne de vous indiquer c'est que les
services qui sont gérés ans picot un spa
vont rentrer dans une chaire une une
cagnotte de compensation de hauteur de
200 millions d'euros dans le plfr il
appartiendra au parlement s'ils le
souhaitent de bouger les lignes sur ce
sur ce sujet mais en tout état de cause
le travail mené depuis maintenant des
semaines avec olivier dussopt
déjà qu'il gourou vous permet
aujourd'hui que nous ayons cette cette
problématique qui soit une problématique
extrêmement importante qui soit prise en
compte
je le disais tout à l'heure ils ce sont
les plus petites collectivités qui en
général avait des services qui n'étaient
pas gérés en dsp et des services qui est
érigée gérer directement en régie et ça
concerne aussi l'ensemble des structures
notamment des spa qui sont des spa qui
souvent étaient des spa support qui
permettait d'avoir des associations de
proximité qui était notamment celles que
vous parlez qui sont constitués de
bénévoles j'ai à dire soutenu par les
collectivités locales sur les
associations elles mêmes est bien celle
ci peuvent bénéficier quand même des
aides accordées aux entreprises dans
certaines conditions les associations
qui exercent une activité économique
peuvent bénéficier parfaitement du fonds
de solidarité
le prix garanti par l'état il faut pas
l'oublier est également assez accessible
aux associations bon vous l'avez dit les
associations employeuses ont pu
bénéficier de l'activité partielle ce
qui était pour elle extrêmement
important mais je rappellerai aussi que
des mesures spécifiques ont été prises
en faveur des associations il s'agit
d'ailleurs il ya un amendement du sénat
sur le 2ème plfr qui a ouvert la
possibilité aux collectivités de
maintenir la subvention attribuée à une
association cas d'annulation
d'événements ou de manifestations pour
lesquelles les crédits avaient été
attribuées faisant en sorte qu'il y ait
pour la première fois une dérogation au
service fait dont je crois que
l'ensemble de ces dispositions plus
celle que nous venons de prendre sur les
problématiques des régies des
collectivités
et va permettre de voir l'avenir avec
beaucoup plus d'optimisme merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur bourgi vous avez 35
secondes si vous souhaitez merci
monsieur le ministre je pensais plutôt à
d'autres types de réponses notamment un
chèque qui pourrait inciter à adhérer à
des associations à renouveler des
licences parce qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'associations nous disent qu'elles
appréhendent de l'avenir avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude parce que des élèves des
enfants qui n'ont perdu l'habitude
d'aller à un club de sportifs ou à une
école de musique ou de danse vont
retrouver très difficilement le chemin
de ces associations c'est pour l'avenir
que je vous demandais des propositions
structurelles cette fois ci avec un
chèque il pourrait s'agir d'un morse
pour une belle au paiement d'une
adhésion ou de la bonne bon merci chers
collègues j'invite à présent monsieur
daniel guéret du groupe l'est
républicain à s'exprimer merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre
chers collègues face à la crise
sanitaire les collectivités se sont
affichés très clairement très souvent
trop souvent les élus ont servi de ton
contre les préfets et nos concitoyens
inquiet face à cette pandémie et aux non
dits de leur état oui les élus que nous
représentons ici au sénat ont répondu à
votre appel
dans mon département l'eure-et-loir un
travail absolument admirable
d'organisation et de gestion en parfaite
coordination avec le préfet a été
réalisée sur les centres de vaccination
pérenne ou éphémères à chartres dreux
nogent-le-rotrou château de maintenon
epernon senonches la lute brutt oury ce
sont toutes des communes et des
intercommunalités qui pour mémoire ne
sont ni des professionnels de santé ni
des experts en tout genre qui passent
leur temps beaucoup sur les plateaux de
télévision
les maires et les présidents urbains
comme ruraux mettent à disposition leurs
personnels organise des transports en
zone rurale assure une veille auprès des
plus fragiles recense les exclus
tellement le système internet que leur
est étranger ou inaccessibles
administrent leurs centres de
vaccination avec des personnels ehpad
admr libéraux pompiers soignants et tout
cela en répondant aux exigences de
l'état sur une main
et en puissance du nombre de
vaccinations depuis des mois ces
collectivités assurent une mission de
santé publique
mais à quel prix chaque métropole a déjà
financé plus de 280 mille euros un bras
de fer s'engage sur la signature d'une
convention de refacturation puisque la
rs remet maintenant en cause le
remboursement de la location et le
gardiennage du site
quant à dreux plus de deux cent soixante
sept mille euros et ce sans compter des
personnels communaux mis à disposition
sur le temps de travail habituel
monsieur le ministre ma question portait
sur les mesures financières concrètes
qui seraient prises par votre
gouvernement pour aider les maires et
les présidents d'intercommunalités à
faire face à une dépense exceptionnelle
financé sur leurs propres budgets dans
une compétence qui au départ est la
vôtre vous avez pour partie apporter des
réponses mais donnez nous la garantie
d'une application rapide sur le terrain
avec le moins de verticalité possible
dans la prise des décisions par vos
administrations je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente
oui monsieur le sénateur guéret les
collectivités locales en particulier les
communes et les intercommunalités
spontanément soutenu l'état dans la mise
en oeuvre de la politique de vaccination
bon déploiement et été un succès nous
permet d'entrevoir la sortie de crise
alors bien entendu nous savons que la
contribution matérielle les
collectivités a bien évidemment un coût
cette question fait l'objet d'échangés
réguliers en février en mars avec les
représentants des associations d'élus à
la suite de ces échanges un groupe de
travail dédié a été mis en place au
ministère des solidarités de la santé
avec les associations d'élus qui a
abouti à l'adoption d'une doctrine de
financement des centres de vaccination
qui vantait par olivier ferrand
une partie des coûts de fonctionnement
des centres est intégralement financée
par l'assurance maladie ou par les
établissements de santé
c'est le cas des professionnels de santé
qui sont mobilisés en dehors de
l'exercice normal de leur activité pour
leur employeur
c'est bien entendu le cas des vaccins
même et s'agissant des coûts supportés
par les collectivités elles mêmes le
firent le fonds d'intervention régional
d aller s est mobilisée dans le cadre
d'une convention pour prendre en charge
les dépenses engagées par la
collectivité au delà de ce qu aurait
généré une activité normale sur le site
ces dépenses qui peuvent notamment
inclure
la mobilisation des agents en plus de
l'entente de travail habituel par
exemple les heures sup les huits kallen
les nuits les astreintes le recrutement
de personnel supplémentaire spécifique
pour les centres de vaccination or
persuadant les soignants qui lui est
pris en charge par l'assurance maladie
et lorsqu elle constitue une charge
inhabituelle les frais de fonctionnement
liées à l'accueil à la logistique et la
coordination
le forfait de 50 kg euros pour 6 mois
évoqué en février n'était pas un plafond
mais un fonds d'amorçage donc tombé
qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion là dessus
et nous restons fidèles à notre idée de
départ de compensation des surcoûts en
prenant en compte les coûts liés à
l'ouverture des centres les week-ends et
les discussions que que mèneront les
municipalités intercommunale se
poursuivront à l'échelle des ars dans le
cadre de ces conventionnement par
ailleurs la possibilité de solliciter
l'appui du est fier a été ouverte à tous
les types de sentent qu'ils soient
labellisés ou non je crois que c'est
vraiment la preuve de l'engagement de
l'état aux côtés de la volonté
remarquable des collectivités locales en
la matière merci monsieur le ministre
j'invite à présent monsieur philippe
mouillé du groupe l'est républicain
s'exprimer merci madame la présidente
lucie me disent mes chers collègues en
raison de la crise sanitaire économique
duo kobe 19 depuis 2020 un certain
nombre de communes accuse des pertes de
recettes importantes concernant
notamment les locaux dont elles sont
propriétaires se pointent déjà été
évoquée par sa tombe de mes collègues
en effet dans les zones rurales de
nombreuses petites communes disposent de
commerces de restaurants dont ils ont
confié la gestion des structures privées
compte tenu de la situation économique
difficile subi par ces commerces les
communes ont été amenés à modérées voire
annuler les loyers de ces commerces
entraînant des pertes de recettes
importantes égard à la taille de ces
communes l'état ayant peu compensé ces
pertes de recettes
l'autre situation que je souhaite
évoquer concerne les sites touristiques
et la gestion des sites événementiels
qui sont aussi gérés par des communes
sous la forme cette fois de régie
là aussi les pertes de recettes pour les
communes sont conséquentes ou total
hélas aucun moyen de compensation par
l'état n'a été prévu dans mon
département des deux c'est ce sont de
toutes petites communes qui gère parfois
des gîtes touristiques qui se retrouve
dans une situation financière critique
et qui voient leur budget de
fonctionnement fortement impacté par ces
pertes de recettes et se turent privé
gestionnaires de sites touristiques ont
été soutenus par l'état
mais pas les régies municipales face à
cette situation l'état at il prévenu de
nouveaux outils ou des mesures de
soutien spécifiques pour ces petites
communes étant donné le recul que vous
avez maintenant regard de l'analyse de
la situation
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
pour votre réponse merci chers collègues
mason ministre oui merci à madame la
présidente monsieur le sénateur bouille
et j'ai répondu jaillir sur ce même
sujet à beaucoup de vos collègues
il y aura donc bien 200 millions d'euros
dans le plfr qui va être délibéré demain
de façon à répondre aux interrogations
qui sont les vôtres alors vous avez
raison parce que ce sont des recettes
qui sont quelquefois localiser celle qui
est sûr en diminution dans un seau
nombre de communes
je citais tout à l'heure les communes
est extrêmement importante mais avec
beaucoup d'équipements lourds des
petites communes qui portent des
équipements très spécifique j'ai cité
les terres mais j'aurais pu citer
effectivement d'autres d'autres
activités comme celles que vous avez
vous-même citez dans votre question et
il ya quelquefois effectivement des
gîtes communaux dès qu'ils sont
relativement importants par rapport au
budget de fonctionnement de la commune
donc c'est un dispositif qui sera donc
je le dis et je le répète une dotation
budgétaire est pas un système d'avancés
remboursables et qui concernera aussi
bien les flics que les espaces qui
permettra à lesparre fallait service fut
qui administratif ensemble ou à caen que
je vous incite les faire de la
balnéothérapie
mais ici il s'agit bien évidemment de
faire en sorte que les deux formes
juridiques qui sont d'ailleurs
quelquefois je suis assez ténue sur la
réalité économique soit prise en compte
ensuite sur le problème spécifique des
loyers que qui est aussi citée dans
votre question je rappelle que la loi de
finances de 2021 prévu une science
initiale a prévu un prélèvement
exceptionnel sur les recettes de l'état
de 10 millions d'euros au profit des
collectivités et des comprendre commune
qui procède à l'abandon ou à la
renonciation définitive des loyers de 2
novembre 2020 dans les mêmes conditions
d'ailleurs que le crédit d'impôt alors
c'est quelque chose qui est strictement
parallèle à ce qui a été fait dans le
privé donc c'est ni plus ni moins
puisqu'on reste dans un système qui est
un système parfaitement équitable dans
la bataille mais soyez rassurés ce que
vous a cité relève de dispositifs que
que nous mettons en
place merci monsieur minier chers
collègues vous avez un peu plus d'une
minute pour répondre ou là une
bonification monsieur me disent j'ai
entendu votre réponse que vous avez déjà
présenté à son de nos collègues salon en
deux points de précisions concernant
notamment l'état de loyer je pense que
les 10 millions d'euros ne sont pas
forcément à la hauteur des besoins au
niveau national on voit bien le geste
qui était fait mais je pense que si on
fait l'état des lieux et vous avez
maintenant les outils pour pouvoir
mesurer ce qui s'est passé il ya un
décalage est donc forcément dans
beaucoup de territoires notamment dans
mon département
on nous a dit qu'il n'y a pas de fonds
disponibles pour cela un l'outil
juridique existe mais le fond les moyens
financiers ne sont pas au rendez vous
donc ça c'est pas premier point et
concernant les prévisions notamment ce
que nous allons voter dans les jours qui
viennent je l'espère l'idée c'est
vraiment d'avant de réactivité sider
très rapidement à voir les mécanismes de
fonctionnement et de prise en
considération et que notamment
on ne passe pas on traite pas en
priorité les plus grands territoires
parce qu'il faut vraiment revenir à la
petite commune rurale
elle associe des indications qui devait
donner parce que par les ans de
traitement des dossiers ce sont souvent
les plus grandes collectivités qui sont
déjà habitués qui ont des services
financiers juridiques qui prépare les
éléments donc il faut avoir ce double
vigilance donc des moyens financiers
complémentaires ceux des loyers et une
capacité de réactivité forte pour les
plus petites communes merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
monsieur bruno rougeron du groupe l'est
républicain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
lutte contre la double crise sanitaire
et économique
les collectivités ont pris leur part à
l'effort national de protection des
français pour n'en citer qu'une la
mienne la région auvergne rhône-alpes
s'est fortement mobilisée pour protéger
ses habitants
sur le plan sanitaire et sur le plan
économique avec près d'un milliard
d'euros investis pour protéger l'emploi
pour traverser cette crise les communes
interco départements et régions ont fait
beaucoup pour suppléer l'état
cependant leur engagement n'a été que
très peu compensé par le plan financier
le plfr 2020 et le pellec 2021 ont
permis de faire des gestes certes à leur
égard mais cela reste globalement
insuffisant comme mes collègues
j'espère que des mécaniques
is me complémentaires seront mises en
oeuvre par le gouvernement
par ailleurs monsieur le ministre je
veux appeler votre attention sur un
point particulier en me faisant le porte
parole de mon département de l'allier
terre de thermalisme la crise sanitaire
et économique a plongé l'ensemble de la
filière thermale dans une situation sans
précédent les zones rurales sont
particulièrement touchés 70 % des
établissements thermaux français se
trouvant dans une commune de moins de
5000 habitants
les secteurs d'activité complémentaires
est fortement dépendant du thermalisme
ont eux aussi beaucoup souffert de cette
crise à titre d'exemple les seuls casino
draine plus de 400 millions d'euros par
an de recettes fiscales vers les
collectivités territoriales sans compter
l'effet d'entraînement sur les loyers
la taxe de séjour ou encore les
ressources liées à l'animation aussi
vous l'imaginez bien la fermeture des
établissements thermaux des hôtels des
casinos des restaurants a eu un impact
considérable sur le budget des villes
d'eau pourtant les spécificités du
thermalisme n'ont pas suffisamment été
prise en compte dans le plan de relance
pour lui fournir une aide adaptée
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire pour accompagner ces communes qui
doivent peut-être plus durement que
d'autres traverser cette crise
économique consécutive aux mesures
sanitaires décider merci cher collègue
monsieur ministre merci madame la
présidente
oui monsieur le sénateur bruno roux jean
alors rassurez vous je vais pas faire
une dotation spécifique pour l'allier
même si ce votre département est chère à
mon coeur mais sachez tout d'abord au
delà de ce que je viens de dire à
l'ensemble de vos collègues sur les
sujets qui sont des sujets connexes que
tout d'abord la lfr de juillet 2020 et à
instaurer un mécanisme qui garantit à
chaque commune à chaque pays à fiscalité
propre que ses recettes fiscales et
domanial ne seront pas inférieures en
2027 perçu en moyenne en 2019
ce qui veut dire que entre 2017 et 2019
il y avait un certain nombre de recettes
l'état versera de toute façon une
dotation égal à la différence par
rapport à cette moyenne ans est un
mécanisme qui était reconduire 2021 pour
les recettes fiscales et par mission 7,6
khalili est le produit des jeux et il ya
la taxe de séjour donc de deux des
éléments extrêmement importants pour les
communes que vous citez l'arrêté
interministériel qui va notifier les
montants définitifs de la dotation sera
publié dans quelques jours mais je peux
déjà vous indiquer que 4168 commune et
51 pci à fiscalité propre ont perçu
cette dotation pour un montant total de
200 millions d'euros
les communes touristiques ont été bien
évidemment les principales bénéficiaires
de ce dispositif notamment pour
compenser les pertes de recettes
fiscales qui sont liées à la taxe de
judée de séjour au produit brut des jeux
des casinos est également la taxe sur
les remontées mécaniques est un autre
sujet mais qui concerne une commune de
votre département
ainsi plus de la moitié des communes qui
accueillent un casino ont bénéficié de
la dotation pour un montant de 62
millions d'euros
dans l'allier par exemple nous avons les
villes thermales de néry et de bourbon
l'archambault qui sont le bien des
bénéficiaires du dispositif les chiens
en revanche aperçu des recettes fiscales
qui sont supérieures en 2020 à la
moyenne de référence dont on n'est pas
dans ce dispositif
ce dispositif en plus ce n'est que le
principal d'une liste qui n'est pas
exhaustive puisque l'état par exemple
rembourser 215 millions d'euros que
l'activité locale au titre de l'achat
des masques réutilisables par exemple à
usage unique et le gouvernement a
apporté un soutien qui quand même hymne
dédié aux collectivités pour
subventionner les dépenses
d'investissements dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure
concernant les stations thermales puis
spécifiquement le gouvernement est très
conscient des difficultés qui sont
rencontrés par ses équipements notamment
parce qu'ils sont exploités en régie
c'est pourquoi dans le cadre du projet
de loi de finances rectificative pour
2021 qui sera débattu la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée nationale puis
au sénat le gouvernement va proposer au
parlement d'adopter un dispositif de
soutien face aux baisses de recettes
tarifaires etc tombent elles vont
bénéficier les les stations thermales en
particulier qui sera j'allais dire un
dispositif puisque beaucoup de stations
thermales en plus sont situés en zone de
montagne
j'allais dire que là aussi sur le plan
avenir montagne vous disposerez
d'éléments complémentaires pour les
stations thermales de zones de montagne
qui sont extrêmement intéressants
or ce n'est pas toujours le cas dans le
département de l'allier je vous le
concède
mais c'est quand même le cas dans
beaucoup de départements de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
je crois qu'avec tout cela nous
arriverons à quelque chose de très
équilibré pour ces communes merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
présent madame elsa chalet que pour le
groupe de républicains vous remercie
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
voilà un an que les collectivités sont
fortement investis pour faire face à la
crise sanitaire
à l'heure où la campagne de vaccination
bat son plein les élus locaux sont à
nouveau en première ligne dans le
bas-rhin ce ne sont pas moins de 26
centres de vaccination qui ont vu le
jour grâce à l'engagement de toutes les
parties prenantes dont 18 centres portés
par les collectivités territoriales à
chacune de mes visites par exemple au
centre de vaccination d'illkirch de
saverne sélestat ou encore de la vente
ce nom une réalité le travail colossal
mis en oeuvre par les élus locaux
accompagnés par les agents les équipes
médicales et de très nombreux bénévoles
tous s'investissent avec beaucoup de
dévouement et ne comptent pas leurs
heures pour que cette campagne de
vaccination soit une réussite
pour ce faire les communes et les
intercommunalités ont dû mobiliser des
agents pour aménager et entretenir les
lieux prendre des rendez vous organisé
la prise en charge des personnes des
recrutements sont actuellement
nécessaires pour faire face à la montée
en puissance de la vaccination et
pouvoir agir dans la durée
tout cela engendre des coûts vous avez
annoncé un fonds d'intervention régional
mais son montant monsieur le ministre
apparaît très éloigné du montant des
charges réelles pour le fonctionnement
d'un centre de vaccination
là où vous indiquer une compensation
allant jusqu'à 50000 euros pour six mois
de fonctionnement
les remontées du terrain font état de
d'un coût bien supérieur à l'estimation
de la dgs les collectivités locales sont
déjà fortement asphyxiés par des baisses
de dotations et de recettes jamais
entièrement compensé malgré ce contexte
difficile
elles ont directement répondu présentes
dans cette crise et ont agi de manière
volontaire et réactive
monsieur le ministre les élus locaux ont
besoin de visibilité
ils ont également besoin d'être rassurés
sur les engagements financiers de l'état
interrogé en mars dernier le ministre de
la santé indiquait qu'un travail a été
mené sur l'énergie
man et l'assouplissement du financement
des centres et que ce fonds serait
abondé autant que nécessaire qu'en est
il de cet engagement par ailleurs pouvez
vous aujourd'hui nous préciser les
modalités précises du remboursement du
fonds d'intervention régional et sous
quel délai cette compensation sera
t-elle versée je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice elle à chalk j'ai répondu à un
autre à votre collègue tout à l'heure le
sénateur guéri sur sur ces questions
sachant que bien évidemment nous sommes
ceux ci des représentants des ministères
de la ministre de la cohésion
territoriale c'est à dire que notamment
pas forcément toutes les réponses sur la
façon dont on met en oeuvre un fonds au
ministère de la santé vous le
comprendrez bien je rappellerai
simplement parce que vous avez évoqué ce
sujet qu effectivement les 50 kg euros
pour six mois qui avait été évoqué en
février
c'est bien un fonds d'amorçage mais en
aucun cas il ne s'agit de quelque chose
qui est complètement définitif et il ya
actuellement des discussions qui se
poursuivre sur ce sujet de façon à ce
que la prise en compte soit plus un
compte différentes le fond d'eux
le est fier dont je ne connais pas les
détails j'allais dire de la façon dont
il est programmé ni mise en oeuvre et
pour autant quelque chose qui existe et
qui permet aujourd'hui j'ai à dire
d'avoir un dialogue entre les ars et les
collectivités auxquelles est
nécessairement des associations d'élus
et ministère de la santé pour que nous
puissions faire en sorte que les
dépenses qui auraient été générés au
delà de ce qui est estimable et
notamment je citais tout à l'heure la
mobilisation des personnels en heures
sup
la mobilisation des agents qui ont été
recrutés spécifiquement pour ce sujet
mais également des charges de
fonctionnement avec une logistique et
parfois extrêmement importante puisse
être prise en compte
donc je puis vous confirmer que l'état
ce ne sera pas absent de ce défi majeur
que aux côtés de seront aux côtés des
collectivités pour relever ensemble ce
défi qui est la campagne de vaccination
je crois que en plus il faut être très
clair ces centres de proximité ont été
extrêmement efficace il ya souvent des
gens que vous connaissez qui sont là
votre médecin votre médecin retraité
enfin j'allais dire des gens sur des
personnes de l2 de proximité que vous
rencontrez tous les jours et je constate
aussi souvent que ces centres sont un
peu chargé par des personnes venant
d'autres grandes villes où ils n'ont pas
la même qualité d'accueil ce qui
provoque dans les petites communes
rurales notamment quelques fois des
dépenses complémentaires de personnel
mais soyez sûrs d'une chose c'est que le
ministère de la santé olivier ferrand
ont bien pris en compte cette
spécificité des centres notamment des
centres ruraux où s'est mise en oeuvre
ce processus de vaccination qui font
d'eux était très important parce qu'il
fallait les juges à dire jusqu'au
dernier kilomètre en la matière merci
monsieur le ministre alors pour conclure
le débat
la parole est à présent à monsieur jean
françois husson pour le groupe des
républicains
vous avez cinq minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il me
revient de conclure ce débat demandé par
le groupe l'est républicain ce qui me
permet de remercier mathieu bernat
alexandra daniel bruno philippe elsa
vous n'aurez plus qu'à mettre les noms
sur celles et ceux qui sont intervenus
pour redresser le les conclusions sur le
coût de la crise sanitaire économique
pour les collectivités territoriales
vous le savez monsieur le ministre a été
rappelé les communes ont été en première
ligne pour répondre à la crise elles ont
été des partenaires loyal de l'état et
même parfois on est était au rendez-vous
pour pallier certaines insuffisances ou
carences elles ont également consenti un
effort très important pour soutenir les
publics les plus précaires que la crise
a d'ailleurs fragiliser les communes ou
leurs groupements ont souvent augmenter
leurs subventions versées aux centres
communaux ou intercommunaux d'action
sociale voire mener des politiques
nouvelles en faveur de ces publics
cibles les départements ça a été dit ont
vu leurs dépenses de rsa augmenté de
près de 8 % en 2020 ce qui a des
conséquences sur la situation financière
d'un tiers de ces mêmes départements
d'autres collectivités territoriales les
intercommunalités les communes les
régions ça a été également dit pas un
certain nombre d'entre nous ont apporté
des soutiens importants notamment en
matière économique ou au bilan le coût
pour les collectivités locales c'est de
l'ordre de 4 milliards d'euros en 2020
rapporte 15 9 dont plus de trois
milliards seraient imputables à des
dépenses supplémentaires et bien
l'impact financier de la crise sur les
dépenses des collectivités à cette heure
est loin d'être définitif et il nous
faudra donc alors que les collectivités
continuent de
de mobiliser des dépenses et notamment
sa vient d'être abordée à l'instant dans
les centres de vaccination alors face à
ce constat se pose nécessairement la
question de la compensation par l'état
de l'impact de la crise sur les
collectivités territoriales qui
contrairement à l'état d'ailleurs n'ont
pas elles la possibilité de s'endetter
massivement c'est qu'elles ne font pas
vous avez vous savez que leurs comptes
sont restés dans des normes tout à fait
appréciable sur ce sujet d'ailleurs je
vais le dire
la position de la commission des
finances au sénat est constante
nous préférons privilégier la
compensation des pertes de recettes
plutôt que de mettre en place des
dispositifs généraux et ou automatique
de compensation des dépenses
supplémentaires
ce constat ne nous empêche pas de
regretter les dysfonctionnements parfois
les plus importants ont été et sont
encore ceux relatifs aux masques ou
honnêtement entre un discours qui a
longtemps cherché à trouver le bon
équilibre et sa voix est là la
compensation l'état a vraiment failli là
où la confiance doit être solide
le sénat par contre à contribuer au
renforcement des mesures de compensation
notamment et vous le savez en
introduisant le filet de sécurité pour
les recettes du bloc communal en 2021 de
la même manière que nous avions obtenu
la baisse du taux de tva à 5 et demi
pour cent sur les équipements de
protection ce qui quand même réduit la
facture pour les collectivités alors si
j'analyse avec lucidité la situation je
pense qu'il ya deux écueils à éviter
le premier c'est celui du catastrophisme
c'est vrai vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre certains dont nous étions avait
des craintes la situation finalement a
été moins dramatique
on aurait pu le craindre mais il ya
aussi un deuxième écueil qui
consisterait à croire que le problème
est quasiment réglé alors qu'il reste
encore devant nous bien des difficultés
et que l'impact d'ailleurs de cette
crise est bien différent selon les
collectivités ainsi au sein du bloc
communal
je veux le redire ça a été beaucoup
abordé mais les communes touristiques
font partie
des territoires et des communes qui ont
été déconnectés les plus affectées c'est
également vrai pour les régies je veux
dire ici au sénat on en a parlé souvent
lors du plf on en a parlé on nous avait
promis dans les deux mois que la
solution serait résolu vous avez pris
quelques engagements mais vous avez
aussi monsieur mise bien compris que les
200 millions qui est que vous avez
abordés seront manifestement insuffisant
eh bien il faudra être attentif parce
que le gouvernement avait initialement
affirmé que la compensation des pertes
de revenus était techniquement
impossible
vous revenez sur 7 comment diriger cette
affirmation et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose
enfin je veux dire peut-être qu'il nous
revient collectivement de nous assurer
que l'impact de la crise nobert rap à la
capacité de nos collectivités locales à
pouvoir investir pour l'avenir
ce serait vraiment regrettable d'autant
que l'investissement dans
l'investissement public local 70% et du
fait des collectivités enfin il nous
reviendra veiller à ce que la prochaine
loi de programmation des finances
publiques sans rien céder à l'impératif
du sérieux budgétaire qui doit nous
animer intègre le rôle décisif que les
collectivités auront à jouer dans
l'investissement
les collectivités locales doivent
prioritairement pouvoir participent à la
relance et ainsi participer à
l'aménagement équilibré de et pour tout
notre territoire
je vous remercie
[Musique]